thank you for having us and my name is
ava Diaz I'll be moderating the panel I
teach at Pratt in the history of art and
design department and I recently
finished the manuscript to a book called
after spaceship earth about the legacy
of Buckminster Fuller in contemporary
art of which the last part of it is
about the privatization of space
different models of ecological injustice
and seeking justice that artists have
been pursuing so it's my great pleasure
to be on this panel and we'll have a
hopefully plenty of time for questions
from the audience and you know we'll
have a chance to talk amongst ourselves
too so I want to just introduce by name
and then let them just give a word about
who they are this is Agnes and she well
you just go down the line Agnes Tomas
Lori and Josh so if you just say one
sentence about who you are and were your
basic hi yeah I'm an artist working at
the experimental edge of art science new
technologies or technologies exploring
the zone between fact and fiction in
2003 I have founded a small Institute
called with a draft for subterranean
science and its chief was mainly to
explore subterranean phenomena and I
developed tools tools to search it's a
whole work series to explore this but
then later I expanded my research
directions I did a project and
weightlessness also an i/o microgravity
and I started to explore phenomena
inside earth but also outside earth and
comparing the parallels in between and I
also renamed my Institute into research
raft Institute for art and subjective
science hello hello hello yes I'm Tomas
Dezi no I'm very happy to be here and I
think so what and and well I come
usually often here I want to say
thank you to Lila kidney Carolyn Jones
and this Pablos well there's a lot of
friends and Janet and Bill McKenna and a
lot of people which usually is it and we
see and women tane conversation through
a time when I come here but the time
that I want to spend here is I have a
lot of sometimes troubles with the other
talks that were before and then one yeah
I'm kind of just well the exercise will
be kind of embraced or may of proposal
an idea and then the first proposal is
still like a you know space at the
moment is or outer space or whatever
name you might say he started 100
kilometers high right this will object
start falling and he's actually now
recalling the Karen I'm lying or
something like this is I mean I think so
there's a lot of problem with with where
space starts and ends and I think so we
should kind of really I think so one of
the big thing and you know the hundred
kilometer threshold you know it's always
a cultural interpretation was not always
at hand it in one Mars two hundred three
hundred then hundreds Amin is a culture
negotiation is constant what I will have
to kind of argue today is like a space
we are in space now and I think so and I
think so these response ability when we
change where space starts and then I
think so will help us to facilitate the
discourse in a kind of a different tone
that's kind of the first thing that I'm
trying to and I will try to think
together as an exercise rate I'm Laurie
Anderson and I mean to stick to the one
sentence I think yeah I'm an artist who
works with stories and lots of different
media and I'm interested in right now in
more of things that have to do with
studying nature of mind and Josh Simpson
I am a glassblower
a glass artist and I have spent the last
nearly 50 years experimenting with
melting silica and flux and and lime and
putting them together making
glasses that are interesting and trying
to make them into some object that is in
tree
interesting to look at thank you so our
brief in doing this panel was that each
of the artists will present for about
three minutes on their work and then we
can open it up I have some questions and
then we can it open it up to the
audience so the order of the
presentations will be first Agnes and
then Josh then Tomas and then finally
Lori so I think that we have the slides
queued up and if you know see I am there
you see
okay I will shortly introduce you to one
very important and large department of
my Institute for art insights which is
the Luna migration bird facility
existing thing since 2008 and it's
moongoose colony which is an ongoing
long-term performance installation and
movie it's actually a method of private
space traveling which was for the first
time mentioned in a book by English
Bishop Francis Goodwin in the year 1603
however the method that allows await
main character to travel to the moon was
with the help of monkeys so and yeah
monkeys are very special migration birds
who like other migration birds travel
annually towards the autumn from Spain
to Africa for example they migrate
annually from the earth to the moon and
I was wondering was what happened to the
monkeys in the 21st century does this
special species still exist do they
still know about a moon migration
pattern or have them been stranded how
could we implement the idea of flying
would it be a genetic awakening or
imaginative awakening experimentally
did they ever fly to the moon really or
do they still fly so in 2011
I have actualized the concept of Francis
Goodwin and I raised 11 monkeys from
birth on a farm in Italy and I teach
them to become astronauts to be able to
fly to the moon with them one day and
first I named the eggs all names are
related to space
travel history here you see the team at
it's an international team at the edge
of 11 days we started with the astronaut
training immediately after hatching and
yeah for example lessons on the space
junk problem and yeah I will show you
two three methods very shortly out of
many many many but there is yeah it's an
ongoing long-term project so there is he
and in the exhibition in front of the
auditorium there's the movie mongoose
colony it's 20 minutes long and it
documents the first year of astronaut
training so you can watch this it's 20
minutes yeah okay so let's have a look
successful and printers are not only
able to teach the Gosling's we have to
sleep and to work what to eat but also
to fly we have to fly and how to get
there
after nine months of strenuous put
successful training we are back to the
mgc home base ready to start the next
stage of the experiment okay I want to
finalize now with some last remarks it's
a long-term mission the first unmanned
flight is planned for 2027 and the first
meant flat for 2038 they have been
already Gosling's born on our moon in
Italy we have built a large moon and I
look there and so the moon goes colony
is growing and the moon is getting
closer and closer thank you thank you
part of my talk it has visual little
photos so I'm counting on this clicker
working okay so glass is this amazing a
chemic stuff that is just sand and and
even borax hand soap and if you put
those two together on a table you're
gonna wait a long time for them to do
anything but if you add 2,400 degrees of
heat they become this molten liquid that
is almost impossible to deal with it's
crazy hot and it drips and flows like
honey it possesses an inner light and
transcendent radiant heat that make it
one of the most frustrating and one of
the most fascinating things for an
artist to work with and what inspired me
originally was when I started to blow
glass in 1971 I this photograph Bill
Anders had taken this photograph just
before and in 68 and I was entertaining
kids who came to my studio and I thought
I should try making planets out of glass
to give them something to think about
small planets they loved what
two marbles but thinking about making
something that would make them think
about this world that we live on that
seems so limitless and large is really
just a small little blue marble in the
black void of space and so I began using
different glass techniques and and
what's challenging about glass is that
it it doesn't want to cooperate it's
just a molten liquid it does not care
about anything really except gravity and
centripetal force and so my trick is to
put as much detail and as much
interesting things and let people
imagine cities or oceans or continents
or large structures on these planets and
wonder perhaps it's an orbiting
transiting exoplanet survey satellite
that may discover them what I've found
over time is that these little worlds
are fascinating to all kinds of
different cultures and races and
different age groups everyone loves them
the other thing that I've been working
on more recently is part of what I love
about glassblowing is inventing new
things I really probably should have
been a chemist or an engineer because I
build my furnaces and I and I work on
these glasses and most people who are
chemical engineers working with glass
are looking for certain optical
properties or certain dielectric
properties I'm looking for color and I
want to that's a fire and you guys all
know this photo and but but what I'm
trying to do in my glass is make you
think about something as cool as or as
distant from us as these sub images and
so the idea is to have you think about
something else
somewhere in the universe but also be
intrigued with a detail that's in them
I've recently become interested in
trying to display or depict a black hole
what would an accretion disk look like
and how can you make something that
reflects light suck light in and this is
this is my studio this is my glass
studio I live and work across the
driveway yeah we're from each other and
this was last Thursday and this is in
warmer times we just installed solar
panels so all the the energy footprint
of a glass studio is like a sasquatch
it's it I but we are now making all the
electric power that we use in in the
glass video and I have two more photos
one is you will all meet my wife Katie
Collman later on this afternoon I was
making planets long before we met
through an accidental wrong number on
the phone in 1990 but but here's one of
my planets this is another project
called the Infinity project to hide my
planets around the world and so this one
is hidden in space thank you
because it's a bit awkward running I
stand here and when you face it back in
the drink to get it here and yes it's
three minutes to go as fast when beef
becomes the hair when I'm through well
atmosphere become the movement of a
specific era against capital capital is
cloud and then let's say that yes if I
cross the three minutes you just tell me
and we will try to keep it in the Q&A
okay today I landed by plane collecting
more points of shame on my golden card
of carbon emission for free means I
don't know how much carbon emission I'd
put it really on this card
well fossil fuel based industry tried to
colonize other planets the air the
interface between us and the Sun is
controlled by fuel and continue to be
compromised carbon emission fill the air
particular matter
float inside our lungs and while
electromagnetic radiation enveloped the
earth dictating the tempo of digital
capitalism in the era of global warming
as we confirm last month in nature
magazine the constant rise of co2 and
other atmospheric pollutant despairs the
tropospheric clouds whose reflectivity
helps to keep the balance of planetary
temperature living a forecast to up to a
degree Celsius this mean today one of
the things that I want to say is like I
feel when I see this rocket just
birthing and putting up and on the cost
that it take that I think so you know
that when we were talking about what was
the event or not the person who was
sitting before about this this moment of
change when you go up and then you have
this moment of I was called the overview
they over the effect I think so these
are really encouraged what is the next
over the effect that we have to have
right is like when I got into the plane
and I came up here I think I got it
really bad over effect I got flowing
over Iceland and then you see the
glacier you see the turbine of the a jet
I mean that's the not and another
overview thing that you have to get and
what is the consciousness we have to get
I mean do we still need together to
remove to get a reality of the planet
that we are living today I think so
there is a problem okay and then we go
on to the other scene the epoch whether
we are trying to to foster and to work
together with some of the people that I
mentioned before we tyrosine we propose
an epoch of interplanetary sensitivity
bring a new ecology of practice asking
how we could breathe in a post fossil
fuel economy and what is our response
ability to be on air now I like the
speed of the word responsibility what is
your ability to respond to be today on
air and how we can change the social
political job job geopolitical borders
in the age of climate inequality how to
participate a new epoch beyond the
Anthropocene forward the decarbonization
of the air and toward independence of
fossil fuel we proposal called the air
sea by promoting let scrutinise free
access to the atmosphere and beyond
through collected activities sensitive
experiences cross-disciplinary
discussion and do-it-yourself we open up
these new spaces again the world spaces
harrison relaxed debate a common
imagination to our nursing Baalak
relationship with the air that we
breathe
I mean I will surely be what what are
these kind of the space agency that we
are trying to to bring up and how we can
get into the air with with this may be a
bill to respond differently in 2070 a
community of people around the world we
started collecting used plastic bag is
very important to mention about the
reusing we cut them we paste them and we
creating
gigantic canvases and when we canvass
unite bands and fold space is full of
air is format and when the Sun Rise have
to out of the horizon and the air is up
inside the space the museum flies into
the air a flying museum that we called
mu zero salar on this era solar journey
gravity becomes
upturned and instead of falling to the
center of the earth we
falling into the universe and this is
why the way I brought a backpack and
tomorrow is a sunny day I think so we
could try to experience what is today to
float in the air and it's a backpack
that even I have been kind of put
together with our friends and in this
community of Edison this mean thanks to
the heat of the Sun that wore up the
inside the space which is inside you
know it just got up into the air and
then when it's obvious that we don't use
fossil fuel batteries and all the kind
of carbon capitalistic ideas of
extracting economy we have been doing it
towards the planet and then sometimes we
do a free fly and this is the project
that we have been doing with MIT that
basically was the collaboration with
apes with lo the vehicle area Glenn and
build McKenna which some of them are
here today and the thing is like what at
what we are trying to do is like if I
will have take from Berlin to arrive to
Boston I should have take off eight
point three days ago I would just say
what it does it just compute all the
wind currents which are kind of natural
rivers of the wind and once we learn how
to float in the atmosphere maybe then we
can try to find a different equation of
our climate relationship with ecology
we're living since I stopped there
because was a bit too long but thank you
um steep you can hear me we can start
the the video we're just going to make a
very quick trip through a virtual
reality work that I just did called to
the moon and it was commissioned by
Louisiana Museum of Art my favorite Art
Museum in the world it's just such a
wonderful place in your Denmark and they
were doing a show about the moon and it
starts out with constellations that
evaporate as you look at them various
ideas that used to be sort of
permanently ensconced in the sky just
become these temporary things dinosaurs
polar bears bees that were democracy
this dinosaur that through some DNA just
turns eventually into a car so there
were lots of stories of originally with
this work and like with a lot of
projects that I work on they they get
drowned in the media that I'm working in
and you don't and they just seem
unnecessary so a lot of this is much
more about flying than stories it became
it originated with a lot of Moon imagery
and ideas about the moon and it kind of
went off in a in another direction
the context of the show was lots of
space gear and lots of theories and and
Galileo matured notebooks and you know
it was really a pretty beautiful show I
hope it travels I think it's actually
going to Norway it just was there so
then you zoom down into this other
fossil fuel thing this of course is him
just a recording of somebody's version
of this but I love about VR is first of
all that you can fly and that's really
the most important thing and in this so
that you you go where you see and I we
this was a seamless originally called
Luna Lago is about
a lot of the debris and militarization
of the moon so there's a lot of stuff in
there there's little references to the
little prince and officers have kinds of
stories about the moon Federoff was also
one of the original characters we it was
also at one point a kind of Russian
mystery about all the using a lot of the
Russian names in the Dark Side of the
Moon but it comes down to everything
that I've done as an artist is about
disembodiment and this is the greatest
technique at the moment for for that
although I think losing yourself you can
lose yourself in a Russian novel you can
lose yourself in a pencil drawing VR
this is one in which the volition just
drops out for a minute and you're kind
of forced to the top of this mountain
where you fall and you lose your body
and it is it is terrifying I couldn't
resist the the scene that's in every
space movie of the astronaut just jumps
out onto he goes out to make a repair
and then of course this cable gets cut
and he tumbles off into space this is a
scene at the largest prime number and
there's this is the only body imagery in
this one it ends with the kind of donkey
ride on the moon and you're you can wave
to yourself as you're as you're riding
along this was a reference to that
lawsuit of the Chinese brought to
international course awhile ago saying
that the Chinese own the moon and of
course the Russians said we were there
first and you know the Americans go no
no no no we put the first guy there and
the Italians go we saw it first
anyway that's it how many times
so this is a bit of an unfair question
because actually Laurie has already
answered it in the New York Times but I
wanted to ask you all about
yosaku misawa's dear moon proposal and
what you think about a tech ecommerce
billionaire sending five to eight
artists on a moon journey he's the first
space X customer for the circumlunar
voyage and we're in the kind of moment
between maybe artist as pet or artists
as being patronized by a patron which is
not a new moment so maybe we could would
you go on that voyage what do you think
about that relationship of art to space
at this moment I think wherever
scientists go
artists it's good when artists go as
well art has many functions so it's
though for me it's important that it
stays free it doesn't need to be aiming
at at the result but it opens up
perspectives it's just supporting other
views and art forms culture so it's a
human condition art that art explores
our world as well no but is what I said
before I think so is the only time I
mean this is a rhetoric question will
you go to Mars you will go to the moon
will you at which cost you know what I
mean this I mean I think so we have to
really kind of shift the question of
saying well you know what I mean is like
it is what I said before at which cost I
came up here today to spoke three
minutes with you how many carbon
emission on the mode of transportation
we have get and isn't mean I would say
yes we go everywhere you want it but the
using plastic bag picked it up from the
bottom of the ocean generating a
community and generating something what
we call you know is like and I think so
is all the rhetoric all the time you
know Felix Guattari when you say that
see ecology is the environmental ecology
the social ecology in the mental ecology
and until we don't have an ecological of
practice establish only is earth and we
can have a certain type of
mobility but not only kind of going
somewhere where we are going we're not
going nowhere and isn't mean let's
really change this overview effect and
then build up some excitement of just
only like it you know when when you see
this cultural leaf tree map you see the
Sun coming up from your eyes on and then
you float and then it's really you
getting to the air is something which is
beautifully silent there's no explosion
there's not rocking there is no noise
that is not cut down you know what I
mean Oh countdown is I mean it is a
completely very beautiful and think so
is lab to us and I think so to build up
these narratives there is another way to
be in space and space it doesn't start
at hundred kilometer is here is among us
let's stop to think about otherwise is
again the cultural division and nature
is outside you're not part of nature I
mean it's how much politics and you know
and you know investment that is to make
us belong not any more to nature he's
the same space is just a geopolitical
and program to believe that we are not
in space let's stop it maybe just once I
mean I totally agree with you what I
said is general the way we explore the
world we live in I don't need to go up
into space for example I'm also very
interested in in space for example
inside smallness it doesn't need to be
you answered it but maybe answer again
from I don't remember what I said except
really excited by that idea and but and
I do think it's a wonderful idea and for
artists to do that I had a very weird
job in 2003 to five I was the first
artist in residence at NASA and it was
really bizarre job I should also say it
was also the last artists nervousness
and why because at one point they were
just they were Congress was reviewing
NASA's budget and they were looking
looking at the same thing going that
like okay thirty Julian for spy
satellites yes you know it's it's very
much about military efforts and as you
know and and they went twenty thousand
dollars for an artist and
it was a whistle-blower guy outraged and
and so I am interested in getting that
reinstated not for myself but although
it was really wonderful to actually go
there not to just think about it to go
there to do these different places and
and but I do think it's important to
have an artist in residence in NASA I
think it would be important to have an
artist in residence in the White House
in Congress in the Supreme Court artists
look at the world differently you know
we have a different agenda a very very
different one so I think that's a good
idea on the other hand when some of my
friends saw that I wanted to do that
chip one of my friends I have a tendency
to say yes to everything and she gave me
a present I just realized I have it with
me it's a pen that looks kind of like
I'm a Greek pipe it's it and so when
people would say would you like to do
the music for an underwater puppet show
it's really interesting and and so she
said you're just going crazy or so
you're just saying yes to everything she
gave me this pen and which is a no pen
so there's a little button here so
somebody says would you like to do an
underground underwater puppet show you
press the button I think like for me as
an artist I really have to think should
I go to the moon or outer space you know
should really do that you know there's
lots of things to do you know so I don't
I have to revise my answer about that
you would not I don't know you know to
your heart I don't know and once you had
I think the experience nothing can
reverse the name do you play X yet yeah
place your own real experience the being
in in this or another reality so I am
very for to go for experiences but going
to the moon I can't answer I like to go
to the moon with my
actually it's a very slow traveling and
so for me for me it's hell yeah
damn yeah get on that and and I actually
I while you're talking I was thinking
about one thing that my wife said in
utter exasperation she said we can send
a man to the moon why can't we send them
all sorry Katie this is a question that
I don't want it to seem too simple but I
want to maybe get at what the stake you
and your artistic practices have in in
these topics of space exploration so
very simply how did you come to make
work about space what was the you know
there's many many things that you could
bank work about and what was the kind of
you know what initiated the project that
you showed and I know for many of you
it's a long investment in space so what
was that kind of originally impetus no
once again because it seems like I don't
know there is this there are not so many
but there are a couple of you John
Powell is a good friend he wrote a book
which is called the other American space
program it doesn't seems like because I
fly balloon it seems you cannot get to
space and I don't want to go to space
yes I want but not with Caravan and
fossil fuel extraction of this planet
and not destroying this planet because
of the addiction we have to certain
economies which are based on fossil fuel
this mean I'm not saying like oh I don't
want to go to the moon and remark but I
want to go in a certain way that I think
so first we have to attune to beyond
this planet and love to be on this
planet with the people which are here
and then see if we can get with certain
sustainable way somewhere else
now forgot the question what was the
other Americans faced on this mean is is
a really kind of a three-stage
architecture that you can really get
into space with light rather than
vehicles I mean when we show a couple of
energy he came to the white Sun we hold
a world record on lifting our person in
the air without burning any fossil fuel
with a certified vehicle within a couple
of years ago and then I don't know if
it's really like a one by one you know
what I mean if you're interested just
keep thinking and and can you know it's
like you can float in the air without
really having such a complicated Boeing
max three that he keep falling from the
air I think so at and nobody knows why
actually I my interest in space came
through the subterranean because I was
investigating subterranean places and I
developed for example these SJM iceberg
probe to investigate subterranean
icebergs and when you look into an deep
ice borehole for example in Antarctica
1000 meter of depth it's pitch black
down there only there from the little
probe light you can see a bit and then
you see the trans more or less
transparent ice horizon slowly passing
by and there are some stones frozen
inside the clear eyes and it looks like
comets passing by so it's really like in
space and I could that's a space travel
and then I started to investigate
parallels between deep ice layers or
subterranean places and Outsiders and
and so on it's just thanks develop like
a resume growing of project lorry was it
than Louisiana invitation or was it the
NASA residence only that particular VR
was was an invitation and a commission
so they already had the subject so but
but I would say mostly I'm interested in
that
just raw energy what that is and
recently I got the flu I don't know how
many if you got this flu this is a well
it's a ten day of flu of like partly
hallucinations and one of the things I
have to tell you that I saw I saw the
same thing for a couple of days today
when my eyes were open as when they were
shot and it was big organic things going
like this raw energy just G just like
and and the room was not there but these
things were there in a kind of solar
system size place and they're all moving
like and they were pure energy and and
so I I just couldn't imagine I thought
what but they have no they're not
differentiated they don't know that one
thing is supposed to be a frog's nose
and another supposed to be your eyelash
and another supposed to be a maple leaf
where does this information come from so
in this whole fever I'm just going back
and forth like how do they know what to
do you know and it was very um so it's
probably that that I'm most attracts me
to this but it's also I've written a lot
of things about stars and and one one of
the songs ends you know the reason I
really love the stars is because we
cannot hurt them we can't blow them up
or turn them out or you know you know
but we are reaching for them and we are
reaching for them so I think that's and
especially at the moment is my
fascination with with that as an
aspirational thing I guess yeah Josh he
spoke a little bit about the planets and
yeah I I think in the at some point in
the early 70s I became interested in
Landsat photos
Edinson and it was interesting looking
at the Earth from a different vantage
point which led me to eventually get a
pilot's license and spend a lot of time
flying
and and also to scuba dive because it's
the same feeling your your your in this
little world and you're floating above
the surface of something whether it's
magical under the ocean or over the
earth and and I think that at least in
my work I think it's our job as artists
to make people wonder and think about
and and posit what it would be like and
to get them excited about things that
sometimes they pay no attention to and
and I wanted to say here come over here
and look at this imagine yourself an
astronaut floating in orbit somewhere
well there's been a lot of techno
euphoric talk in the earlier panels and
I think what what interests me about the
work as you've described is there's a
deep investment in the materials that
you're I mean you have your training
crew in the country and with Tomas the
work is really invested in how to think
solar energy as an available resource to
us without having to rely on fossil
fuels with lorries work it's like trying
to get into VR as some way to unfold
experience differently like as the kind
of material reality of how disembodied
one feels and that and then to kind of
imagine that projective space as a
speculation into futures and with Josh's
to imagine this kind of visual material
relationship that glass has to liquid
molten qualities of the earth itself
it's a very self reflexive position you
know to be in as a glassblower to kind
of think yourself as you know sort of
maker of worlds you know but I think
that we I just see zero there so we are
out of time but we want I wanted to have
some time for questions which I hope we
have a few minutes for so so does anyone
have any questions okay I think there's
that on tissue box or whatever it is it
can Dave it yeah
thank you so much all of you for your
your presentation and your ideas I feel
like something that could be a question
for any of you or all of you sorry if
I'm not in the light or something how do
other species the perception that other
species might have of space or their own
wealth in general might help us ask the
questions about space or answer them
differently
how's the way other the way other
animals see the world how can that help
us ask the questions about space in a
different way mm-hmm
feels like you're touching with a goose
it's maybe some of your work to the
spiders a lot of your password maybe was
music and animals and also all the
creatures that you're creating so so
post humanism and space
how do we kind of think differently
about access I imagine you know what
does it mean to for us to strive no no I
was thinking just like it because
spiders also do a method which is called
ballooning is the way I would also they
emigrate and then something which is
very beautiful also in relation to
reader movements and the idea to moving
is something which is called stillness
in motion and it's mean just a little
bit I will go back to the human but then
I'll also let's try to remember how the
spider it kind of ride this kind of
rivers of the wind isn't mean if we will
be kind of in a in a solid balloon let's
put it that way that I've all been only
for humans in history of my humanity who
have lift up from the air without
burning any fossil fuel without using
high long hydrogen this mean these are
the real heroes for me lets me put it
that way the astronaut I love them but
from there epoch is being the one who
can lift up without a burning is good
now when you're in this kind of solar
balloon and you do have sometimes the
journeys have been very very short a
couple of kilometers this means you just
the Sun come up you rise with a balloon
because the hot air is there if we could
be talking with Ava and I look at her
hair right
here in do not move one millimeter well
you watch 10 meters down the ground and
the trees are shaking like crazy
look at her and help move the hair
doesn't move you move with the wind
there is not for more friction anymore
this will not explain in a sailing boat
in any other mode and this mean that
maybe is an overview effect is like
becoming there will not move in the wind
you move with the wind and this mean
your brain is really get confused he's
like because I see the hair hair he
doesn't move and I watched on retreats
and he stopped when you move it away and
you become the wind and it's just a
great question it's because you know we
ship like a hour and spiders and just
use them as kind of a instead of really
studying how they actually communicate
with each other which would we would
learn an awful lot more about how we
might approach communication and I have
two cats that don't seem to care that
much about art they do like things that
roll like my planets yeah but I mean of
course it's very enriching but it's a
question of communication and I have
spent so much time with my monkeys they
have their own communication structures
and I it's the process to find ways how
to communicate with each other I mean we
have set up we have developed some
communication devices for the geese so
they have their own control room and
they can send us with Morse code data
about their general well-being and about
the experiment but it's still it's it's
really a challenge to communicate with
the total other a specie I don't know if
you but for example until now I didn't
find the key to initiate take off when I
won't let's say okay now okay let's take
off and fly but it happens that
one goose you hear a signal and then
they take off and fly from one mountain
to another but I didn't find a key and
so it's a question of communication
methods to develop a common language or
never I don't know if it's possible
oh my question there oh no more okay
sorry we're out of time but thank you
all so much